في هاتف Huawei الجديد تم اكتشافه
من قبل الباحثين في Tech Insights Carrie
mgy اه هو المدير الإداري لتلك الشركة
للهندسة العكسية وهي
تنضم إلي الآن أم لقد كنت أنت وفريقك
من اكتشف هذه الشريحة المتقدمة
أريدك أن تخبرني كيف
اكتشفتها  وما هي مخاوفك
الآن حسنًا، لقد كانت
بضعة أيام مثيرة أه اه وغني عن القول اه
تم إطلاق الشريحة في وقت سابق من الأسبوع الماضي اه
خلال زيارة جينا روندو إلى اه
بكين وذهب فريق المصادر لدينا للعمل للحصول
على أيدينا  أحد أجهزة
Huawei mate 60 Pros أه، ومع موجة
من النشاط، تمكنا من الحصول على واحد إلى
مقرنا الرئيسي في أوتاوا بكندا
حيث كان لدينا فنيو ومهندسون المختبرون لدينا
على استعداد لأه هدم
الجهاز الذي يتضمن أه استلام
الجهاز في أوتاوا وفي غضون سبع
ساعات تمكنا من إجراء
عملية صارمة للغاية لتمزيق
الجهاز وأيضًا استخدام بعض من
قدراتنا البحثية الخاصة جدًا في المختبرات للكشف عن
الجهاز أه داخل هواوي  M 60
Pro، إذًا ما الأمر بشأن هذه الشريحة
المتقدمة،
أعلم أنك تعرف متى تم الإعلان عن جهاز mate Pro،
كان يتحدث عن
القدرة على إجراء مكالمات عبر الأقمار الصناعية ولكن
لم يقدم أي معلومات حقيقية عنها
القدرات الصحيحة، لذا فهذه القصة
تدور حقًا حول الشريحة الموجودة داخل
الهاتف الآن أه قبل عام أه
سنيك، حيث
كشفت الشركة الدولية لتصنيع أشباه الموصلات أه عن
عملية 7 نانومتر الخاصة بها مما يعني
أنهم كانوا قادرين على أه بناء
شريحة صغيرة جدًا  أه أم القدرة،
وبعد مرور عام، يقدمون إلى
السوق شريحة أكثر قدرة أه أه أم ولكن
الشريحة نفسها تسمح بقدر أكبر بكثير من
قوة المعالجة وبالنسبة
لسؤالك حول مكالمات الأقمار الصناعية أه،
فهذا شيء نواصل
القيام به في  تحليلنا أه للتأكد من أن
هذه الإمكانية
تبدو مضيعة كما هو معلن عنها، وأنتم
كمشرعين قلقون للغاية بشأن ما
تعنيه هذه الشريحة المتقدمة، وقد ذكرت
هذا سابقًا أن الولايات المتحدة قد
حظرت بالفعل أي تكنولوجيا اتصالات جديدة
من مختلف الشركات الصينية بما في ذلك
هواوي و  أمثال ZTE في العام الماضي،
لذا أريدك أن تعطيني فكرة عن
السبب وكيف ينبغي أن يكون هذا الأمر مثيرًا للقلق
بالنسبة
للغرب. القلق على وجه التحديد هو
أن الصين تتحرك أكثر نحو
استراتيجيتها للخادمة في الصين 2025 في
حقيقة ذلك  إنهم يقدمون
معدات تصنيع أشباه الموصلات لمقدمي
الخدمات المحليين مثل ERS مثل Smic لتكون
قادرًا على إجراء بعض هذه
العمليات المتقدمة، وما رأيناه فيما يتعلق
بالقيود التي فرضناها
نحن المشرعون ولكن أيضًا
دول أخرى حول العالم هي  الحد من
شحن معدات التصنيع الرئيسية
إلى أه الصين للسماح
للمصنعين الصينيين بمواكبة ذلك، لذا فإن
الأخبار المثيرة للاهتمام التي تأتي من
وجود sen 7 نانومتر n plus2
مما يعني أن الجيل الثاني من
عملية 7 نانومتر أه هو حقيقة أنهم
قادرون على  استخدام المعدات الموجودة
المتوفرة لهم داخل الصين
لبناء هذه الرقائق